there's a huge Chipotle exploit where
you get a taco and you overload the taco
because double rice is free double beans
is free double lettuce is free double
cheese is free double all that's free
and then you ask for a side of tortilla
which is like 50 cents and you just pile
the entire Taco into the burrito
tortilla and it turns out to be three
bucks wow they patch it this girl she
posted this Tick Tock it got like 20
million views it went super viral okay
and then there was this huge controversy
because everybody started going to
Chipotle using this exploit I don't
think they've patched it because I don't
know how they would